-According to a new report
"Pokémon Go"
was one of the top-grossin
mobile games in 2019.
And with that news --
-Hey! Bl-bl-bl-bl!
Hey, everybody! Hey!
It's me -- Squattle,
your favorite Pokémon character!
Bl-bl-bl-bl!
-Oh, boy, everybody.
It's Squattle.
-That's right, Seth.
Throw your balls at me!
[ Laughter ]
Bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl!
-Yeah, no. We -- We go over this
every time you're here.
In "Pokémon Go,"
it's just one ball, singular
-Oho! That's no fun!
[ Light laughter ]
Throw your balls at me, Seth
Bl-bl-bl-bl!
-So, Squattle, Squattle,
are you happy
that "Pokémon Go" is
the most downloaded mobile game?
-Oh, you bet. [ Chuckles ]
It makes me want to
"Pokémon Go" out to dinner
with my friends to celebrate
Throw your balls at me, Seth
[ Laughter ]
Whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo!
[ Light laughter ]
-Hi, everyone.
It's me, Seth.
And I'm actually here
with some sad news.
The writer playing Squattle in
the sketch you're just watching,
his name is John Lutz,
and he is currently in a coma.
You see,
after we taped tonight's show,
John got into a severe acciden
where -- and this is true --
on his way home from work,
he somehow fell up
eight flights of stairs.
[ Laughter ]
Now, we were gonna cut
this sketch
from tonight's broadcast
because it bombed
in front of the live audience.
[ Light laughter ]
Just bombed.
But because John is in a coma,
we've decided to air it
in his honor.
So, please,
do keep John in your thought
while watching
the rest of this sketch.
[ Light laughter ]
-Look at me dancing!
♪♪ Cha-cha-cha, one, two, three
♪♪ Cha-cha-cha,
throw your balls at me ♪♪
Whoo-whoo-whoo!
Whoo-whoo! Whoo!
[ Light laughter ]
-Now, let me just explain
the backstory of this sketch
So, back in 2016,
when the "Pokémon Go" craz
was in full swing,
John wrote a script
about a fake Pokémon character
named "Squattle,"
the Squattle you saw tonight
And that sketch did, well,
you know, fine.
Then 2 1/2 years later,
at the request of no one,
John brought the character back,
and based on the audience'
lukewarm response to that one,
we all assumed that was the last
anybody was gonna see Squattle
[ Light laughter ]
But then, lo and behold,
John brought the character bac
a third time,
based on today's barely news
that "Pokémon Go"
was one of the top-grossin
mobile games of 2019.
Still, we all, you know,
we all hope John pulls through
from the coma.
And, you know, with that,
here's more
of our beloved John Lutz
as the unbeloved Squattle.
-Seth, this next song is calle
"The Squattle Fart Fart Dance.
Fart, fart, fart!
[ Laughing ] But don't push me
too hard in the tummy,
or something else will come out.
[ Laughter ]
A Squattle poopy!
[ Light laughter ]
-Now, I understand you may b
thinking a few things.
You might be thinking,
"Seth, you don't seem that hot
on the Squattle character.
Correct -- Squattle is bad
and I don't like it.
Why, then,
you might be wondering,
did I bring it back
for a third time?
Well, John has two children.
And he came into my office
tears in his eyes,
and said Squattle
is the only thing they like,
which I later learned was a lie.
[ Laughter ]
After I spoke to John's wife
after the fall,
she said specifically
they do not like Squattle --
it gives them nightmares.
He lied about his children
[ Light laughter ]
And you may also be wonderin
how one falls up
eight flights of stairs.
Well, John was wearing
the Squattle costume.
And due to the way it's
designed, it's very top-heavy.
And when the costume falls
it creates its own inertia
and propels itself forward
in a way
that totally defies gravity.
It's like a loaded dice.
It's actually very impressive.
As to why John was wearing
the Squattle costume home,
he told us all
he might run into Squattle fan
who would want to get
a selfie with him.
[ Light laughter ]
I mean...
Anyway, please enjoy the end
of the Squattle sketch.
-Seth, I'm throwing my balls
at your desk!
[ Laughter ]
Ha-ha-ha-hoo!
[ Light laughter ]
-[ Chuckling ] I mean, it is -
I love you, buddy.
It is worse --
worse than I remember.
[ Light laughter ]
What? What's that?
Oh, he -- [Chuckling]
he made a full recovery!
Oh! That is --
That is great news.
Thank you. Thank you.
So, on that positive note,
please enjoy the end
of the sketch the final time -
the final time --
the final time
we will see Squattle.
-See you next month, everyone!
-Squattle, everybody!